allora allori da un anno è uscito sto
gioco più o meno tantissimi di voi ma
tipo tutti mi avete chiesto di farlo pur
essendo un gioco reggi che anche se il
medico mi ha detto che non dovrei farli
perché mi si gonfia troppo la vena sul
collo stato perché un tasto e punto
esclamativo all'altro due punti
esclamativi a con questo ti abbassi con
questo salti molto chiaro allora la cosa
otto vite quante sono le dieci vite bene
porca eva sono state esattamente dopo
dopo maca vacca sul bordino proprio
bello preso ben due bordi ok
bordino però stiamo leggermente di meno
arca vacca quast'anno veramente
rasentando il ridicolo e come dove ok
piano piano perfetto piano questo è una
trappola quindi devo saltare nel vuoto
sicuro non sono pazzo sacco di giochi
devi fare così
saltiamo giusto ok
raga io vi giuro vi ammazzo cosa vuoi
che faccia una mia vita spiega mi se
salto va indietro se santo va no
credibile no non c'è ora non so non so
come ho fatto ve lo giuro non so come ho
fatto
avevo praticamente farmi scivolare giù
porca eva se ci arriva con in mezzo
ok e poi saltare dall'inizio occhio no
disintegro la stirpe ragazzi cioè io ve
lo dico no no non avete capito io vorrei
di massacro tutti se vi uccido veloce
ok o chiocchio cosa succede di aiuto
dovevo andare in quel buchino liszt
commento è ma vorrà un pò avrei mai
detto ma porca vacca chicchi che
inventato sta roba ma scusatemi c'è il
gioco più brutto del mondo la porca
vacca e no lo toccava alla
mi sa di no cosa devo fare spiega mi to
me lo dite poi cosa devo fare e non so
veloce
eccoli no no no no no ma dai
cosa vuol dire qualcuno ragazzi e una
minima idea di come finire st parte devo
continuare così per tutta la vita non lo
fate sapere prima grazie a dio
grazie cos'è sta roba aiuto devo addio
siete scemi ma cos'è sta roba
porca vacca ma come faccio come si fa a
scendere scusami aiuto aspetta che
arrivò già faccio sono fatto ci credo
che ho fatto
cos'è in acqua e se va beh sa fa il
super mariano posso scendere anche
velocemente porca eva lo schifo cosa no
no no dài dài
e vabbè cosa deve cosa devo fare lì
scusami non aspetta non ho capito quindi
ecco cosa come dove dovrei come perché
provano a non andare a respirare vado
direttamente cristoforo colombo concia
morta ma che c'era una parte si creò
chiocchio che sta morendo di di mosca
eva è morto di respiro ai vai vai vai
vai vai vai
non è vero ma anna non riesco a farlo
neanche sapendo dove devo andare veloce
veloce ma dai
cribbio
cos'è se va beh io dovrei riuscire a
fare qualcosa
sono molto a caso se va beh ma si dai
vabbè tanto guarda eccolo
no perché sono cavalca ce l'avevo fatta
non saprò mai più ma io sono io dove
passa quello vado dove passa quello vado
lì perché vado dove passa quello cioè
c'è un chilometro l'autostrada vado dove
passa quello io vado dove passa quello
vado lì no no no no no e no no no no no
no no no sono passati sarà a parte mia
mi ha saltato il livello lo stesso va
bene ho avuto un culo incredibile così
star o mio dio devo andare c'è questo è
un sottomarino va bene fin qua sera la
donna
ok miglio fenomeno bravissimo per morirò
subito però vabbè
se va beh cosa è sceso godzilla non
parte che non vedono anche dove sto
cliccando figure ma va a cagare va poi
evitare di lanciare bombe tanto non
servono a niente non fanno danno a
niente stai facendo solo casino puoi
evitare il lancio alle bombe grazie
veramente non serve a nulla quello che
stai facendo tranne uccidere me stesso
lanciare le bombe non serve a niente
cosa stai lanciando cosa stai lanciando
non serve a nulla
non ha senso che era gabba st c'è
veramente con tutto l'amore del mondo
basta per adesso mi fermo qua perché
veramente infatti sta roba è legale fare
una roba così cioè non so io comunque
spero di avervi divertito anche se non
mi son divertito io per niente fatemi
sapere se volete continuo dipende dalle
views e dalla mia voglia di vivere per
ora concludo quasi contento di aver
giocato asta pattumiera io sono proprio
contento di scoprire ogni giorno giochi
nuovi mia è una passione che gli porto
da piccolo purtroppo e si vede siete un
sacco come al solito se video è piaciuta
sul momento mi piace anche la ricerca di
transizione iscrivetevi al 7 prestiti
noi ci crediamo
ho capito bene
[Musica]